I got 30 seconds is David drinking gin
nope
oh we got the same machine
oh she probably knows this line
um why am I playing the maruti that's
horrible that's the worst okay because
you're the beginner
oh I should have gone A5 first
okay
David's not drinking gin he's drinking
his own tears
okay I'm gonna tip my hat to some of
these ones
dude they're asking for your insta
oh A4 David and Real Madrid shot yeah
baby
if I have to close my hoodie just to
hide the belly
so I am gaining some Advantage now but
time is
somewhat running out
some of these I just don't understand
let's see what she does trolls
NASA finally reaches oh yes Bishop D1
that's nasty
she's playing really well yeah she's
playing Super well this game G4 okay I
gotta go for uh you can speed yeah yeah
he's accelerating the play guys and
girls
far too loud on this game
wow this is gonna be clipped all over
the Internet okay okay okay okay so
settle down settle down oh I jinxed it
settle down
this
is you're not rooting for me nah nah
much hair I can't root for anyone with
so much hair
come on Alexandra
yeah the Bold Community is going to take
good care of themselves
okay
this is not gonna gonna be easy okay
take it
would be foreign
all right over here because Alex bring
the king push the Pawns
the situation unlike David's head is
getting a bit hairy
[Laughter]
all right keep it coming come on guys
come on
Bring it on I can take it
fairly safe safe pre-move but okay
oh you're doubting yourself there 11
seconds Jesus
did Kaya teach David how to hide his
belly on camera oh wow that's just
guys
thank you pikush
after long calculations
[Music]
I love it I would love it if she's if
she plays rookie yeah
they'll be so cool that would have been
the perfect moment to stream tonight
oh I was not expecting oh maybe I have
to bring the king first
this is not going to be easy
ah good move annoying
she goes for a kitchen three
I should just I have to gamble on some
of the premiums trust your ass
wow David there are products and
surgeries that can help with your
hairline not to do nothing to do with
the face there
oh wow this is
I am tense
okay she has to she has to uh do
something dirty at some point that's
that's her uh
I mean she could maybe survive yeah
look at this okay trade
now I cannot lose
are you just gonna take the pawn
wow some of these roasts
oh she's in time
oh
foreign